at first we were able to leave messages
and then her voice mail became full yes
and then you rang and then you just got
the recorded we are unable to write
leave messages at the moment and this
was gone I saw I was used to hearing
that and we gone up to the Birdseye
building to look at the CCTV and we were
sitting downstairs in reception and I
rang her phone yes and it clicked
through on to her voicemail so I heard
her voice yes and I was it was just like
a job she's picked up her voicemails Bob
she's alive and I was just it was then
really look when we were told about the
hacking that is the first thing I
thought yes mm-hmm so you'll meet your
immediate reaction mr. phone jenna is
that right Gemma yes I spoke to Gemma
and and then it sort of died down
afterwards because you're thinking oh is
that the only reason that could have
happened or or what have you but it was
jus it was the guy told my friends all
she's picked up her voicemails picked up
her voicemail